la segunda ola de la pandemia en italia
supera por mucho los peores momentos de
marzo el país alcanzó el miércoles el
millón de contagios de kobe 19 y sus
cifras son más críticas que antes
mientras que en la primera ola de la
pandemia italia escasamente registró más
de 6 mil contagios diarios este número
se disparó desde mediados de octubre
hasta llegar al récord de los cerca de
40.000 diagnósticos positivos en un solo
día a principios de noviembre
y tal como ocurrió en los momentos más
difíciles del inicio de la pandemia los
hospitales del país europeo ya no dan
abasto en castellammare di stabia un
municipio cerca de nápoles
las ambulancias hacen fila esperando que
los centros de salud puedan atender a
los pacientes y en la ciudad napolitana
las personas aguardan en sus carros a
las afueras del hospital cotugno a la
espera de alguna pipeta de oxígeno
en milán la capacidad para tomar pruebas
ya se saturó
si tenemos en cuenta una estimación muy
aproximada se podría hablar de que
alrededor del 1 por ciento de la
población de milán está infectada y por
eso se entiende cuán grande es la carga
de trabajo para los laboratorios y otras
instituciones que realizan las pruebas
aunque italia fue noticia mundial a
principios del año por ser el primer
país europeo en declarar cuarentena
total hoy esa medida aún no se aplica en
todo el país sin embargo el gobierno
impuso un toque de queda nocturno y
dividió a italia en tres zonas más de la
mitad de las regiones están catalogadas
en riesgo naranja y rojo lo que
restringe la movilidad de las personas
en un intento por frenar el virus